on top of their luxurious facilities and
food the sponsors of the next segment
the sterling club is also about healthy
youthful skin we stopped by to learn
more
i am adriana martinez i am a medical
institution here at the medical spa at
the sterling club we offer here an array
of services from
fine dining to working out we have a
huge spa we have a outside facility at
the medical spa we offer all kinds of
treatments to improve your skin
conditions
to delay as much as possible the aging
process that we all hate today we
actually did a demonstration of our prp
treatment prp stands for plasma rich
platelets we draw the blood
the blood gets into a centrifuge we spin
it out for about 10 minutes the blood
separates the red blood cells goes on
the bottom it's a thin thin layer of the
white blood cells which are immune
system cells and the transparent light
yellow liquid is the plasma the plasma
contain if you want the core of
ourselves
that's the reason that is so effective
once injected what applied over our skin
what is the outcome and this is what
people really see they come back and
they say i can see my skin is lifted i
can see i got a new toners of my skin um
they also tell us especially uh people
after 50 60 they realize that their dark
spots are fading out because the prp
it's actually promoting a seal healing
replenishing kind of system
within the skin replenishing all the
cells that are dead old or not
functioning with the new one and as the
new one comes out they are healthy they
function healthy they function in sync
with each other and of course
melanocytes which cause the pigment are
the one that will be replaced as well
and that's where they see when you look
with no pigment whatsoever in addition
to plasma being injected in the skin we
chose to do third module over because we
cannot inject plasma in every single
inch of the skin so we chose to put
plasma over the skin mixed with the
hyaluronic acid and some protein and
then we follow up with the homage
thermage it's a very simple definition
of it pretty much stands for fractional
radio frequency it's used as and known
as the lifting firming treatment it
really firms the skin and affects the
skin mainly more than muscles it reduces
the appearance of the wrinkles so you
can imagine the combination between
radio frequency and plasma they both do
the same thing they stimulate collagen
and water behind the surface of the skin
and improves the appearance of wrinkles
thermage is also used
all over the face neck eye area
our clients tell us about a week after
the treatment that they notice affirming
on the neck and corner of the eye
i had clients that came back and i said
uh my i left my eyes literally looking
like i have a lift my eyebrows are
lifted so these are the main
benefits of thermage
give the sterling club a call at
702-732-9700 or find them online
thesterlingclub.com
las vegas now will be right